now breaking news coming in the American
comedian and actor Bill Cosby has just
been sentenced for drugging and
molesting a woman in 2004 we'll get the
very latest from Gregg Milam he's in Los
Angeles bring us right up to date Gregg
yeah the judge in that that case of
sentenced Bill Cosby to between three
and ten years in prison for that
conviction of aggravated indecent
assault he was convicted back in April
of an incident that happened in 2004
when he indecently assaulted a
basketball coach andrea constand the
sentencing has been taking place over
the last half an hour or so and the
judge very much referencing Andrea
constants words about the impact that
this crime had on her life and continues
to have on her life to to this day and
handing down what is in effect the
maximum sentence having made some
decisions yesterday the judge pretty
much allowed ten years in prisoners the
maximum sentence well he's announced
that sentence will be between three and
ten years so after three years Bill
Cosby could apply for parole but we're
talking about a man who's 81 years old
his lawyers had said he shouldn't go to
prison at all he should have been
confined at home because he is legally
blind he's unable to get around himself
but the judge with some very strong
words in his sentencing about the impact
that Bill Cosby has had on on his
victims life and why he is handed down
such a stiff sentence and a sentence
that many people will be delighted about
the trial had heard from a number of
women who weren't part of the the
alleged defense but people some of those
dozens of women who've made allegations
about Bill Cosby and his conduct very
similar conduct over the years and were
allowed to address the trial about what
had happened to them to show a pattern
of behavior and for many people the
sentence that was being handed down
today was about that pattern of behavior
not just about this one offense but
about Bill Cosby in general and some of
those who say they've been his victims
over the years will be delighted that
the sentence is the maximum that was was
possible for these offenses under the
under the state law some 60 women have
made those as accusations now Bill Cosby
has made it clear through his lawyers he
plans to appeal
whether he will go to prison while that
appeal process takes place will wait to
see from from the judge because that's
something that could take many many
years but as it stands at the moment
Bill Cosby is going to prison and going
to prison potentially for ten years for
those those crimes that he was convicted
of earlier this year